it's almost like you look at at a
picture it's like you're almost not the
same you're that's not the same person
but you it is clearly it is it is but
it's like wait a minute is was that me
or is that the same person and then you
realize oh it's different now but I know
you mean about like well then you get
into Behavioral Systems and wiring and
like and then we just we could we would
have to do another inside yeah inside
inside of your but actually but that's
kind of what you're doing Michael I mean
you're going this road this journey of
what's inside of you and sharing it so
yeah you know I think the vulnerability
of that you know I think vulnerability
is probably a key thing isn't it yeah I
think it's if if you're not showing
yourself and you're you shouldn't be
preaching it you shouldn't be telling
people how what they should be doing if
you're not also at least acknowledging
it right I don't know really it depends
on the depends on the context right you
don't need your therapist to start
crying in front of you or to tell you
about something right that's true that
would be kind of odd on that would not
be Prof I had a therapist once uh say
you mind if I E the Subway sandwich in
front of you I'm just really hungry I
haven't eaten it was when you did in
person I go yeah that was my last do you
ever have that like a I I was I had an
acting teacher once in college said you
got to get rid of that that that judging
eye that's always talking to you and
looking at you and if you can shatter I
think there's four those the ID the ego
and the super ego and if you can shatter
old school
paradigms Robert with the old school
parad old scho old school Paradigm but
you can't get how do you get rid of that
like you that conversation like shut the
[__] up like that voice that judging
thing if you can shatter that thing but
then again is it even can he even do
that I think for a lot of actors they're
always like not a lot of actors but
artists and sometimes that voice thing
gets in the way like you need to [__]
shoot that thing with a shotgun mhm and
then get
I I agree but I also like I don't think
I'm cool enough to just
internalize oh you well you're just how
you inter have you always been like that
where you can just sit there and be I
don't know how the F that's a gift can
you do that Bret can you just sit and
shut the [__] up and internalize no I my
girlfriend says Jesus you never stop
talking you come home and I'm like well
I have to talk to somebody and you live
here so sorry that's your job part
you can you can leave if you don't like
it but you can talk to us she's like
don't you need to rest your voice for
this show